Let's start by looking at birthdays using ggplot. Ggplot is a
graphics package that allows us to make visualizations. We're using ggplot
since it's easier than the base graphics that comes with R.
It has some nice features, such as the format of plots and
legends that are automatically generated. The first thing we need to
do is to download and install the ggplot library. Now that
we have got the ggplot loaded, let's use the qplot function
to plot a histogram showing the number of users whose birthdays fall
on any given day. I can run their name pf
command to get an output of all my variables. Now, I'm
trying to create the date of birth by day histogram
for all my users. So, I'm going to use the date of
birth day variable, here. For the qplot function, I'll pass
it two parameters, x and data. X is going to take the
variable of data birthday, and data's going to take the variable pf,
which is where all my data comes from, from the pseudo
Facebook dataset. Running this command, I see my histogram come
out in a plot window below. Now, you might notice that
this plot is slightly different in color. If you're curious about
setting color and themes in R, see the instructor notes. Getting
back our code in console, you can see that we
get this warning message, when we run the code. This is
fine for now but, you should think about what this warning
message means. So, here's our histogram so far but, I want to
add one more layer to this plot. Let's fix the label on
the x axis, so we can see everyday of the month here. So
to adjust the x axis, I'm going to add a + sign right
after my code and then hit Return. This immediately takes me down the
next line with a little bit of indentation right here. I'm going to
add the layer scale x discrete and then give it the priority order
breaks from 1 to 31. This is because I want all my
days to be 1 to 31, the days of the month. And running
this code, we can see we've done a little bit
better. What are some things that you notice about this histogram?